uh oh this can't be good major crimes
division just called they're taking over
your murder case the vulture is on his
way here now no
doesn't that guy get tired of stealing
our cases he took one for me and rosa
last week
you made us run up ten flights of stairs
it's over
thanks guys
i got it from here
don't worry we can stall them until you
get the confession we rehearse this you
guys this isn't a drill everyone know
their assignments all right hands in
commence operation broken feather and go
okay guess
i don't have a lot of time i need your
full signed confession we have four
minutes we can do this but i'm not
guilty listen to me gus we can do this
son
yo
is this a police station or a toilet
because all i see is turds
attack the pembroke
[Music]
oh no i spilled coffee on you by
accident
lucky for you this wipes off quickly
this coast made out of whale skin
the vulture still flies the vulture
still flies
hey pembroke what do you say we go talk
about a case in the break room oh yeah
what case is that the case of how you
got so damn sexy god owed me a favor
okay so
i told you i didn't know the guy you're
lying we have pictures of you two come
on we only have three minutes it's like
you're not even trying to confess the
vulture is coming we need more time
someone do something i got it
tear gas
scully
wrap my spoon around your face
and out of the tear gas
guys is the phoenix
i got it from here
all right fine
i'll just go then
with this fully signed confession we did
it guess whoa
suck it vulture i killed that guy and
his neighbor but you were too late
wait you killed his neighbor
i got a call
that the restaurant is locked i can't
keep running down here and doing your
job for you donna right i got five to
six businesses huh your brother said the
restaurant was locked so i biked back
from work sorry honey then why did you
come nick cause your husband's slow
that's why
wait is that
yeah this guy little stinker he's simple
famous five-hour i guess what she get
for that i just found out about this
well we can't have it for free we need a
new walk-in the lamb's gonna keep coming
back to life
track down that old manager of yours i
bet he's got some money for you larry
no this is the only one or my nine or
ten businesses is losing money find
larry get the money wear the jacket on
the commute love you sis
hey what's up bro
what's up jake got a little update for
you on that berg assault case turns out
the victim's wife was
super hot yeah i read the file she's a
mom
not interested true that
so listen
i've been thinking
we got off on the wrong foot here and i
believe
it's cause we're just too damn similar
you do absolutely we both love premium
tequila yeah robin thicke oh yeah gots
to have my poops that's dude and of
course most importantly nip slips let me
ask you a question jake you also like
okinawan martial arts because
you left this in my back what i'm saying
einstein is that you stabbed me in my
back how so
we came up with a plan jake is going to
befriend the vulture so he lays off of
us busted i knew that you were faking it
i'll bet you don't even like nip slips
so what you bugged the briefing room no
scully butt-dialed me yesterday and he
still hasn't hung up
once again scully's butt is the downfall
of this precinct look jake i know that
you and santiago are trying to take me
down you guys go home you lay in bed
together you plot against me well no
longer i want you to dump santiago and
that's an order what you can't do that
it's completely against the rules okay
sonia sotomayor i would never break the
rules but what i could do for totally
unrelated reasons is have you busted
back down to a beat cop no
don't do that all right
i can learn to love nip slip no you
either love them or you don't it's too
late you dump santiago or you kiss that
detective badge goodbye
beat it
yo you know scott you guys having
trouble you know i saw a man's shadow on
the nest cam last night
you cheating
he was with wiki you have a nest cam
yeah it's my apartment
your song senso
it's not a song yet i used to have
dreams you know what i wanted to be
keith hernandez i had to give it up
because you know you can't be another
person the science is not there yet
i'm not giving up i
i just need something to write about
like
dolly parton wrote jolene about a bank
teller that flirted with her husband
perfect go to the bank and when you're
there you can deposit
last night's cash and don't let them
tell you they can't accept it if it's
wet all right i got a bunch of other
stuff here
you're looking for inspiration
i just handed you a whole album and you
better take me to the grammys and not
mom i'm not holding up restaurant sauce
on the red carpet oh yeah i am love you
[Music]
oh
hello peralta
oh
no no no i know why you're so upset man
i'm the one who had to come to this
backwater stink hole
what's up little man what's up you
feeling sexy huh yeah i feel sexy that
you look sexy you know i do it's out for
that door
yo how much you bench seriously hey you
know before i solve this case i'd like
to thank you for doing all the super
easy work you know the real nancy drew
level stuff oh yeah did nancy drew solve
a lot of murders yeah she did murder on
ice recipe for murder nancy was a
wonderful detective i wanted to be her
when i grew up thanks charles that's
helpful hey should we take odds on how
fast i'll solve this case no i mean what
was it with diaz's last impossible
extortion case what was it six hours
that's because it was 98 percent solved
the last two percent's hardest to get
that's why they leave it in the milk
what
oh wow
looking good santiago gonna foxy ma go
rotten hell this is your fault
thanks champ good effort i got it from
here
and hey
you feel free to call me anytime you
need me to come down here and help
powder that big white ass of yours
well
that's the worst thing that's ever
happened to me
[Music]
hey you know that um i see our mist
that's not freeing i dropped it into
this cup and now i'm cleaning it up with
my mouth
wait a second
i know that look
you got the vampire glow going on
[Music]
are you feasting on youth
yes
i am dating a younger guy i finally get
why men do this they're so firm and
happy welcome to the club hey um how
young are we talking here maybe 20. how
many abs
oh oh boy
20 with abs now with that comes a lot of
upkeep
this is how you keep them on the hook
you take them to atlantic city on their
birthdays twice a month you get them
jewelry here's a hot tip pave is still
diamonds but it's cheaper and most
importantly take the erection pill when
the appetizer comes we are not alike
unlike you i'm a hot and captivating
woman i admit that you're way better
looking than me i had to get that but
there's a clock on these things right
one day
you're getting out of a hot tub naked
and they realize that your butt crack is
only an inch long and bam
it's over a second alarm goes off no in
my circles the december always dumps the
may you know this whole thing about a
woman exploiting a man sexually
personally to me it's disgusting that's
2015 so god bless it's 20 21. don't
fight man everything right
peralta just texted he knows where the
hostages are he wants 15 more minutes
and i want my lesbian neighbors to be
way hotter than they are but we can't
always get what we want right
i'm ordering that raid hey give that
back to me are you serious i will end
your career you'll be out there working
as a model because well you know you're
shredded and i respect that give me that
walkie-talkie now those are my people in
there
you are not gonna give that order
stand out no stand down or i'm gonna
make you hey you turned get off the roof
to help me get off
[Music]
you